morning John I'd like to make a quick
logical argument two postulates followed
by a conclusion postulate one creating
is terrifying postulate two everyone
creates logical conclusion then being
that everyone is terrified it's actually
not creating that's terrifying
it's it's sharing the creation or even
the thought of sharing the creation
that's terrified because once your
creation is in front of another person
you have lost all power you've gone from
the situation which you have maximum
amount of power over this thing that you
have made to no power you have
nothing that's not true actually you
have all of your hopes and dreams and
values and aspirations and days or weeks
or months or years of work that you've
poured into this thing that you're now
sharing with the world and the world has
every right to despise ya terrifying
right now on to the second postulate
that all people are creators and now
we've sort of been set up to believe
that this isn't necessarily the case
that we live in a world where Steve Jobs
makes an iPod and we buy an iPod but
that's not how the world is even if you
have no way of physically creating a
thing you create ideas and you create
jokes and you create friendships and
then you have the creation that matters
most to all of us and that is the
scariest and most dangerous and most
intimate and most beautiful creation
that everybody gets to make you only get
to make one of them that's the self this
is why I totally hate it when people
give the advice to just be yourself
because like who is that we aren't born
with a self we create ourselves you make
you you make you out of the books that
you read and the expectations of culture
and the interactions with your friends
and your family and in a million other
factor is because the self is this
terrible intense creation and the most
important creation that we all make when
someone tells you that they don't like
that thing that's terrible which is why
talking to a stranger is always scary
like to me anyway I don't know I feel
like everybody must be like this to some
extent because when you talk to a new
person you are making you inside of that
and you don't want to do a bad job and
that's why we all fear judgment so much
because judgment is just someone
creating you inside of their head
without your permission without full
knowledge of who you are they're making
you but they're making you improperly
instead it's terrifying
it's absolutely terrifying there are a
few ways that I found to make it less
terrifying you can create the bare
minimum of creation you can not try very
hard that's good you can you can be
really bland you can just create really
bland things that look like everything
else that everyone else has ever created
where you can create things that you
don't care about at all or for people
who you don't care about or you can just
never ever share the things that you
create and of course all of these
strategies are terrible ways to live
it's terrible to see people doing this
with their creations but the most
terrible creation to see people do this
with is their cell trying to be boring
trying to look like everyone else are
worse not trying at all which has led me
to the belief that you know as a creator
how worthwhile your creation is by how
terrified you are I've only ever found
one solution to this which is just to
create to create in spite of fear and
create constantly to create for children
and adults and your parents and your
idols and your peers in your community
and to consciously be creating yourself
every day to make you the you that you
feel best inside and create friendships
because I honestly believe that friends
are the commodity by which we should all
be judged it's the only way that I found
to temper the fear of creation just to
create constant because to be clear the
fear doesn't go away you just get more
comfortable in it John I'll see you on
Tuesday